après la répression la terreur en chine
le gouvernement chinois a fait exécuter
cette personne ce matin à pékin conseil
du rpr philippe seguin rentrer dans le
rang les dirigeants refusent la fusion
avec les autres partis de l'opposition
nouvelle inculpation dans la sphère des
fausses factures du sud est cette fois
il s'agit de proches de la politique à
gauche et à droite
l'homme de la mer est devenue immortelle
commandant cousteau été reçus cet après
midi à l'académie française il est notre
invité nouvelles mesures de prévention
contre le sida une expérience d'
échanges de seringues pour les
toxicomanes dans 300 bonsoir le
commandant cousteau sous la coupole
s'est fait depuis cet après midi l
océanographe le plus célèbre du monde
mais aussi il faut le savoir le français
le plus connu dans le monde entier
le commandant cousteau donc a été reçu à
l'académie française
tout à l'heure c'est bertrand
poirot-delpech qui l'a accueilli et qui
a insisté sur trois mots qui définissent
bien le commandant cousteau indépendance
imagination et libertés
brigitte simone et en juniors le
cinéaste l'explorateur des océans et le
protecteur de la nature prennent place
dans la voiture officielle de son
domicile à l'académie française quelques
kilomètres seulement ledit la salle yeux
commandant cousteau 79 ans pour les
parcourir
comme la tradition l'exigé l'iran en une
heure de discours omaha chercheurs de
l'est dont il occupera désormais le
fauteuil l'ombre immense d'un homme
exceptionnel dont l'oeuvre m'est
étrangère que je n'avais jamais
rencontré et dont il m'incombe et de
prononcer l'éloge tradition toujours il
ne parlera pas de lui mais on sait
depuis jeudi dernier jour où on lui a
remis son épais que pour lui le combat
continue il descendra plus que jamais
l'antarctique
16h30
il appartient désormais au cercle très
privé des 40
le commandant cousteau est devenue
immortelle
voilà
voilà ça c'était cet après midi bonsoir
commandant cousteau suarez heureux de
vous recevoir ça fait quel effet d'être
immortel en dehors de la tenue sur
apollo c'est la tenue qui m'intrigue
montage ça me fait encore rien d'abord
parce que je trouve qu'on meurt quand
même beaucoup sur la coopol dix mois on
connaissait l'océanographe le
scientifique le cinéaste est maintenant
donc l'immortel est au fond est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas et c'est d'actualité
le premier des écologistes à le produire
sur iah jeu parfait de mais en tout cas
convaincu oui à l'écologiste qui s' il
ne pense que ça et vous sentez en accord
avec justement les écologistes qu'on
entend beaucoup en ce moment
pas tout à fait mais si vous voulez le
fait qu'ils aient des succès électoraux
je ne pense pas que ce soit nécessaire
je pense que ça jette une certaine
confusion née après tout ce ne peut pas
faire beaucoup de mal et anthony la lgv
esther qui est le leader en france du
parti écologique
c'est un garçon sérieux il était cet
après midi oui sous la coupole et il me
plaît donc j'espère qu'ils se soient pas
trop roulé par le système politique que
nous connaissons les vous avez beaucoup
combattu pour l'antarctique et brigitte
sy monial rappelé il sent maintenant que
les dirigeants politiques du monde
entier semblent vous suivent ça doit
vous faire très plaisir encore trop tôt
du monde entier on peut pas dire ça donc
ce qui est mais revenir à que le déjà
c'est que la france et l'australie ce
soit entendu pour défendre l'idée d'une
réserve internationale en antarctique
tenu bon d'autre part déjà la belgique
vient de voter une loi interdisant à ses
ressortissants
toute exploitation en antarctique
nous attendons beaucoup de l'italie
également il restera quand même à
convaincre des gros morceaux comme les
états unis l'urss
je parle pas de la chine parce que pour
le moment je crois pas qu'on puisse
faire grand chose
ça viendra peut-être bientôt mais pour
le moment on peut pas y toucher
je l'aï regardé et pays on voit de pas
en voie développement des pays très
importants qui sont pas parmi les grands
comme le nahd par exemple ou le japon
qui ont un rôle considérable à jouer
aussi
donc nous avons dit 6991 énormément de
travail si nous voulons convaincre tout
le monde
alors on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
mais dites moi on connaît plus de vous
le scientifique que littéraire quels
sont vos goûts en matière littéraire
vous avez les auteurs préférés
oui mais mes goûts littéraires ne vous
plairont pas beaucoup pourquoi ce que
parce que je n'aime pas la fiction c'est
à dire que les romans de l'intérêt ce
plan c'est quand même aujourd'hui
la littérature c'est pratiquement les
romans merci commandant cousteau merci
d'avoir été notre invité en tout cas
voilà et on va rester sous les océans
vous allez le voir la transition et tv
puisque on va parler maintenant du
bismarck c'est le plus gros bateau
allemand qui avait été coulé pendant la
guerre est bien il a été retrouvé dans
l'atlantique la semaine dernière on vous
en avait parlé aujourd'hui nous sont
parvenues les premières images du
bismarck claude crespo une épave
étonnamment élégante encore d'aplomb ce
sont les mots mêmes de bob malach le
scientifique américain qui la semaine
dernière a retrouvé le bismarck droite
comme une maquette à l'échelle humaine
elle disait par 4600 mètres de fond au
large de brest
bob malach le voici aux commandes de son
navire tracteur équipé d'un robot jason
junior une technique déjà utilisée avec
succès il ya deux ans pour retrouver le
titanic
en coulant le bismarck emporter jusqu'à
ce jour
beaucoup de secrets la technique
notamment du thé les pointages des
tourelles le titanic en 87 a été
disséqué grâce à ce petit robot des
assiettes des bagages pratiquement
intacte ont été récupérés l'équipe du
professeur ballard apportera-t-elle des
réponses à bon nombre d'énigmes
serons-nous maintenant si les allemands
ont sabordé eux mêmes leur cuirasse et
peut être aussi les cales de ses
bâtiments livreront la réponse à la
légende d'un fils qui aurait été tournée
par l'équipage lui-même avant le
naufrage
le retour de la barbarie en chine cette
exécution capitale la nuit dernière et
sans doute beaucoup d'autres qui se
préparent comme nous vous le laissions
entendre dès hier le pouvoir chinois a
décidé de réprimer le plus durement et
le plus sévèrement les trois exécutions
de shanghai hier n'était pas et des
exemples isolés cet homme ce matin donc
ont reçu une balle dans la nuque à pékin
dix-sept condamnés à mort ont aussi été
exécuté à jinan dans le nord-est du pays
il paraît que cette fois ce sont des
condamnés de droit commun
et pendant ce temps là les arrestations
continuent avec aussi un élément nouveau
dix personnes ont par exemple été
arrêtés pour espionnage au profit de
taïwan c'est encore le retour à des
pratiques d'une autre époque
michel mompontet sur les écrans de la
télévision chinoise ce soir un nouveau
masque à la répression
après les banques disent et les voyous
contre révolutionnaire voici les espions
venus l'étranger
tout d'un coup ce n'est plus un bond en
arrière de dix ans effectue la chine
mais de 30 ans l'époque de la guerre
froide
ils viennent de taïwan ils ont font
monter les derniers trous de la place
tiananmen qui sont eux les responsables
l'épreuve les voici des armes et talkie
walkie l'inventaire est minutieux
regardez bien ces photos
elles ont été prises sur la place
tiananmen elles prouvent leurs activités
subversives
aucun doute vous pouvez les reconnaître
vous-même l'étranger responsable des
maux de la chine
une technique de répression qui n'avait
pas été utilisé ici depuis 1957
le seul fait nouveau aujourd'hui et sur
le visage de ces accusés pas de traces
de coups comme sur les condamner des
jours derniers la classique position
d'humiliation à genoux la tête baissée a
également été abandonnée
peut-être faut-il voir là un effet de
l'indignation internationale
en effet bien minces en vérité et puis
d'autres fait significatif encore c'est
par exemple un militaire qui vient
d'être nommé rédacteur en chef du
quotidien du peuple l'organe du parti
communiste chinois
quoi qu'il en soit la chine s'est mise
au ban de la communauté internationale
dans le monde entier unanimement on
condamne les exécutions après le grand
élan de démocratie du mois de mai on
condamne mais on ne prend pas beaucoup
de sanctions comme par exemple le font
les états unis
de toute façon la chine a immédiatement
pris et les autres pays de ne pas se
mêler de ses affaires à washington et
jacques à bouchard
les états unis regrettent profondément
les exécutions en chine une déclaration
un peu à la sauvette de la part de james
baker secrétaire d'état et tout était
dit du côté américain george bush est
resté muet sur la question
pourtant les journalistes sont revenus à
la charge à six reprises dans la journée
d'hier en pure perte
pas d' escalade verbale pas de menace de
sanctions commerciales
cette prudence de la maison blanche
n'est pas du goût des membres du congrès
qui réclame une riposte ferme envers
pékin
des élus se sont d'ailleurs rendus en
délégation à l'ambassade de chine à
washington reçu ensuite au capitole
l'ambassadeur a fait le dos rond en
écoutant ses visiteurs manifester leur
colère face à ce qu'ils dénoncent comme
un acte de barbarie
la réplique de la statue de la liberté
installé face à l'ambassade de chine n'y
change rien jusqu'à présent pékin
accueilli avec le plus grand détachement
les deux seules initiatives la maison
blanche
des appels à la clémence et l'embargo
sur les ventes d'armes américaines et
les six nouvelles exécutions de pékin
de la position d'attenté choisi par
george bush tout simplement intenable
voilà pour ce dossier chinois se ce soir
en france rebondissement dans la sphère
de la sorme a eu la faire des fausses
factures du sud est une escroquerie qui
aurait servi les partis politiques et
bien aujourd'hui il ya une nouvelle
inculpation à gauche comme à droite
gérard monatte par exemple proche du
parti socialiste ou à droite des proches
de l'udf jean claude gaudin les
inculpations qui interviennent au moment
même où un projet de loi se prépare sur
le financement des partis politiques
hervé brusini et oui il y en a pour tout
le monde à droite comme à gauche
l'offensive judiciaire persiste et signe
gérard monade d'abord l'ancien chargé de
mission auprès de gaston defferre
l'ex-syndicaliste policier siège
désormais sur le banc des trente deux
inculpés du dossier pour les enquêteurs
le schéma et saint urbain technique
l'une des sociétés de gérard monatte
aurait fait le lien entre des élus du
parti socialiste et la surnomme la
filiale pour le sud-est du numéro un du
bâtiment français l'asm
l'entreprise se voyait attribuer les
marchés locaux à coup sûr contre espèces
sonnantes et trébuchantes verser urba
technique mais secret oblige tout cela
se serait fait par fausses factures il y
en aurait pour deux millions cinq cent
mille francs
un architecte un directeur administratif
chargé de mission urbaco cnic sont eux
aussi inculpés à paris dans les bureaux
très discret de la société on ne
souhaite faire aucun commentaire
même schéma même inculpation pour
georges farinacci cette fois un proche
de jean claude gaudin le député udf jeu
farinacci aurait réalisé des travaux
pour les dernières campagnes électorales
sa société sun communication aurait fait
pour 730 mille francs de fausses
factures décidément les rumeurs d'
amnistie en matière de finance
politiques semblent pas avoir ébranlé
pire culié le magistrat chargé de la
faire le conseil national du rpr
pas question de fusionner avec les
autres partis de l'opposition c'est ce
qu'on dit en choeur tous les dirigeants
aujourd'hui il refuse donc la
proposition faite par valéry giscard
d'estaing hier et puis dans cette
dernière journée du congrès on a aussi
remarqué l'attitude prudente du
rénovateur philippe seguin laurent
boussier scène inhabituelle au rpr un
vote à bulletins secrets pour l'adoption
d'une motion de synthèse et de texte
présenté par les responsables mais
plusieurs fois amendée
scène inhabituelle toujours un conseil
national ouvert à la presse où des
dizaine d'orateurs se succèdent pour
encourager ou critiquer les dirigeants
celle inhabituel enfin les rénovateurs
avec philippe seguin en tête
applaudi par tous les membres du conseil
national
je n'ai jamais eu le sentiment au cours
ces derniers mois que notre mouvement
était à l'agonie
j'ai la conviction qu'il pourra être ce
soir plus fort et résolus que jamais
depuis longtemps les rénovateurs qui ce
soir semble rentrer dans le rang au
moment où trois de leurs principales
revendications sont adoptés à une très
large majorité officialisé la création
de courants représentés à la
proportionnelle dans les instances du
rassemblement adopté la mise en place de
liens organiques favorisant l'union de
l'opposition adopté le principe de
primaires à la française pour la
désignation du candidat à la présidence
de la république pour préserver l'unité
du rpr jacques chirac a donc lâché du
lest en accompagnant un mouvement qui
risque de lui échapper
nous sommes d'un rassemblement par
vocation et donc il est bien évident
qu'il existe chez nous des sensibilités
différentes comme on dit aujourd'hui
des courants pour s'exprimer au goût du
jour c'est évident adopté par 240 9 voix
contre 13 les textes proposés par la
direction ont refait ce soir l'unité du
rpr une unité dans laquelle pourront
maintenant s'exprimer quelques diversité
voilà ce qui s'est passé donc au rpr ce
jeudi alors jean-louis de seine philippe
seguin en principe cet état rénovateurs
est-ce qu'il est rentré dans l'ordre au
fond la question peut être posée
autrement
peut-on à la fois rentrés dans le rang
et reste et rénovateur pour philippe
seguin
la réponse est oui il avait d'ailleurs
lui toujours parié sur la rénovation de
l'intérieur du rpr
contrairement à d'autres mais en échange
de sa bonne volonté évidente et après
avoir réaffirmé sa foi boulistes il a
obtenu pratiquement tout ce qu'il
voulait
le rpr n'est déjà plus tout à fait ce
soir ce qui n'était hier un parti uni
directionnelle et centralisé à outrance
mais par la même occasion jacques chirac
retrouvent paradoxalement un peu
d'oxygène
il a accepté bon gré mal gré la
rénovation qu'il redoutait naguère il
n'en est que plus fort pour contrer les
assauts d'un giscard au meilleur de sa
forme depuis dimanche dernier
depuis qu'il a remporté au nom du lion
d'opposition les élections européennes
qui est leur l'autre grande idée de la
journée c'était la fusion udf rpr à
peine l'idée lancée par giscard hier
elle est déjà abandonné aujourd'hui vous
savez valéry giscard d'estaing dégaine
très vite seulement voulant dégainer le
plus rapidement possible pour délimiter
son territoire et exploité sur le champ
sa victoire le rpr ne pouvait que lui
rappeler que la victoire était commune
et rejeter son offre de fusion rpr udf
ans physicien d'apolitique jacques
chirac et avec lui l'ensemble du rpr
ressouder pour l'occasion lui ont
répondu en choeur tout phénomène de
fusion est forcément réducteur des
leurres giscard se retrouve face à son
propre camp face à un léotard qui veut
le mettre au rancart après l'avoir
soutenu face à un cds qui malgré la
défaite de simone veil continue de
vouloir affirmer sa propre personnalité
au sein de l'udf
pas facile dans ces conditions
d'envisager des primaires de toute
l'opposition pour la désignation en
toute sérénité d'un candidat unique pour
la prochaine présidentielle
merci jean louis mais justement pendant
ce temps là les centristes du cds réunis
c'est aussi eux non plus ne veulent pas
de fusion ils restent sur leur quant à
soi
ils sont le sait très courtisé véronique
sainte olive c'est un paradoxe les
centristes n'ont jamais été autant
courtisé le mauvais score de leur liste
menée par simone veil ne les a pas fait
tomber dans les oubliettes
bien sûr ils revoient leurs ambitions à
la baisse plus question de se saborder
pour devenir la colonne vertébrale d'un
grand parti du centre n'est pas question
non plus de se donner au premier venu
les centristes attendent de voir ce que
les prétendants mettront dans la
corbeille de la mariée
moi je souhaite travailler avec tous les
hommes j'ai pour l'avenir les
propositions concrètes je souhaite
répondre au désir des français que ce
soit monsieur léotard monsieur giscard
d'estaing pour monsieur chirac
je ne fais pas de différence je ne fais
pas de différence nous avons besoin des
uns des autres et je ne veux choisir
aucun homme en priorité car les
présidentielles c'est pas demain c'est
dans six ans
pierre méhaignerie peut sourire les
centristes sont toujours vivants et
incontournable jusqu'à souhaitent les
récupérer à l'udf
ils ne reviendront au bercail ou s'ils
obtiennent une parité absolue avec le
parti républicain
léotard leur propose de jouer à 200
giscard il oppose une fin de non
recevoir
chirac leur fait les yeux doux ils
répondent que dans la construction d'une
maison on ne met pas le toit avant les
murs ou sein de l'opposition qui se
cherche pierre méhaignerie et ses amis
vivent leur vie
la psychose des seringues sur les plages
après cap d'ail
il y a quelques jours cannes un enfant
encore été piqué hier par une seringue
usagée cela s'est passé sur la croisette
un endroit pourtant bien surveillé et
nettoyer la psychose vient bien sûr du
fait que les seringues usagées et
transmettre des maladies y compris sida
en fait il faut tout de même savoir qu
après un séjour dans l'eau sur la plage
il n'y a qu'une chance infime pour que
le virus soit encore actifs et pendant
ce temps là le gouvernement poursuit sa
politique de prévention contre le sida
l'une des causes de transmission ce sont
vous le savez les seringues lorsque les
toxicomanes se les passent les uns après
les autres alors le ministre de la santé
claude evin a décidé de tenter une
expérience originale l'ouverture de
trois centres où l'on échange des
seringues d'usagé
contre des 5,9 c'est en seine saint
denis à marseille et à paris
le centre a ouvert ce matin à paris
alain labouze pour ce jeune incapable
pour l'instant arrêté la drogue
il n'est pas question d'attraper le sida
alors il vient ici avec son sac jaune
pour échanger ses seringue salle contre
des serins prendre c'est gratuit c'est
anonyme
et même si cela peut paraître choquant
il ne s'agit pas de favoriser la
toxicomanie
mais bien de lutter contre l'épidémie de
sida est la préoccupation de médecins du
monde c'est seringue sida quand on voit
exactement ce qui se passe que dès qu'il
ya un enfant qui explique sur une plage
comme on a vu depuis deux jours avec
tous les médias qui se jettent dessus
comme si c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et de terribles on se
rend bien compte que la yaris qu'un film
par contre lorsqu un toxicomane prend la
fringue d'un toxicomane séropositives et
se pique avec il a une chance immense
d'attraper le virus du sida
donc le seul problème c'est qu'il est
des fringues neuf et propre
les deux psycho man sont les plus
menacées par l'épidémie de sida
il fallait donc faire quelque chose avec
les changes du soral qui démarre
aujourd'hui et la vente libre en
pharmacie continue toujours
c'est un dispositif d'urgence qui s'est
mise en place voilà la formation
pratique maintenant puisque nous parlons
de ce sens très bien dans son adresse
là où on peut échanger donc les
seringues usagées contre des seringues
neuves
c'est à la mission france 1 rue du jura
dans le xiiie arrondissement de paris
un tout autre sujet maintenant on a
retrouvé les fins ge vous savez il
s'agit de ces animaux qui servait à la
recherche médicale et qui avaient été
enlevés fin mai par un commando qui
s'apitoyait sur le sort des petites
bêtes
on en a retrouvé 28 sur 38 qui avait été
enlevé apparemment les singes n'était
pas au désespoir car leurs ravisseurs
les avaient évidemment bien traiter
certains de ses ravisseurs sont entendus
en ce moment par la police agnès poirier
les 28 singes ont été retrouvés dans
cette ville-là des alentours de bandol
dans leurs caches d'origine et en bonne
santé ont précisé les policiers les deux
jeunes médecins qui loue à la villa il
et venait régulièrement s'occuper
transféré à lyon
les deux suspects devraient être
inculpés de vol avec effraction
le 21 mai dernier un commandant
s'étaient introduits dans les locaux de
l'inserm à lyon et avait emporté une
soixantaine de singe de chiens de chats
et de l'apa c'est un acte de désespoir
devant les abus commis au nom de la
science avait déclaré ce groupe
d'amoureux des animaux se fait appeler
arche de noé c'est un acte de terrorisme
avait affirmé les chercheurs de l'inserm
qui effectuer des expérimentations sur
le système nerveux central les
transplantations cardiaques et le sida
une soixantaine d'animaux reste encore
introuvable
ils ne sont pas dangereux précise-t-on à
mi-terme que policiers de la sûreté
urbaine de lyon enquête parmi les
militants pour les droits des animaux
qui pourraient avoir pris en pension
les animaux volés dans l'actualité
internationale on doit encore je ne sais
pas quelle est la caméra qui me prend
l'une l'autre voilà on a encore retenir
cette déclaration de monsieur
rafsandjani l'un des principaux
prétendants à la présidence de la
république iranienne est l'un des hommes
forts de l'iran il était en visite en
union soviétique il a affirmé que la
menace de mort sur l'écrivain salman
rushdie était toujours d'actualité que
la mort de l'ayatollah khomeini n'avait
rien changé
alors voyons tout voyons tout cela et
d'autres informations internationales
avec éric perrin signature d'accords
bilatéraux importe entre l'urss et
l'iran la visite de chimie rafsanjani
amiral berbatov aura permis aux deux
pays de développer leurs relations
économiques politiques
le président du parlement iranien qui a
décidé de prolonger à titre privé son
séjour a par ailleurs rappelé que la
condamnation à mort de salman rushdie
subsister
la france et l'allemagne de l'ouest
iront au sommet européen de madrid avec
une volonté commune d'avancer
prioritairement sur le dossier monétaire
et le dossier social le chancelier
helmut kohl et le président françois
mitterrand ont souligné à la suite d'un
déjeuner de travail la nécessité de
trouver un calendrier raisonnable pour
la mise en place de l'union monétaire
le sommet de madrid s'ouvrira lundi
prochain
l'alcool pourrait être à l'origine de la
collision entre le paquebot soviétique
maxime gorki et un iceberg un médecin
norvégien qui a participé au sauvetage a
déclaré que certains membres d'équipage
effective au moment de l'accident
au point de ne pas pouvoir participer
aux opérations de secours
douze heures après celui ci version
contestée par d'autres sauveteurs les
américains ont le droit de brûler leurs
drapeaux
la cour suprême des etats unis a estimé
en jurisprudence que cet acte pouvaient
être assimilées à l'exercice de la
liberté d'expression telle qu'elle est
garantie par le premier amendement
cette décision dans un pays où le
patriotisme est une vertu à fait là une
guerre de tous les médias éclipsant même
les exécutions en chine
les français à leur affaire quand il
s'agit de parler de vin ils sont
toujours les premiers or en ce moment
même à bordeaux se tient vinexpo c'est
le plus grand salon du monde sur le vin
des milliers d'acheteurs et de vendeurs
venus du monde entier
parmi eux bien sûr les américains à qui
les français vente 100 millions de
bouteilles chaque année il n'empêche que
ce n'est pas toujours facile de traiter
avec eux maryse mano et jean louis
normandin sont allés aux états unis
fouiner dans les caves à vin pro portage
la porte que tous les new york et rêve
de pousser pour l'ouvrir aux crochets de
la serrure et le mur bascule découvrant
70 mille bouteilles de grands crus
français
la cap d'agde de la prohibition ici
listées lors réserve ses bouteilles sans
avoir sa fortune
c'est tout de même une clientèle aisée
qui fréquentent les détaillants en vain
ici le revenu du client dépasse les 20
mille francs par mois
ils n'achètent pourtant pas à n'importe
quel prix je ne suis pas dans les
affaires pour vendre une bouteille comme
un rembrandt à quoi bon faire du cinéma
autour d'un grand vin si le bordeaux
n'est pas un rembrandt il lui ressemble
du moins dans la publicité qui n'hésite
pas à associer le vin à la france est
très apprécié par les américains cette
nouvelle campagne vise à maintenir les
vente de grands vins aux etats unis car
depuis 85 le port du new jersey décharge
un peu moins de caisses de vin en
associant le vin français à la mode
comme nous l'avons paix prendre un
certain nombre d'années le prenons le
risque de conforter cette image de
france et de vins français un petit peu
inaccessible
donc nous avons opté pour un concept
plus facile d'accès pour les américains
qui est celui de l'association avec
l'art français et notamment les
impressionnistes
les impressionnistes et dont le trafic
devrait répondre s'il est plus ne flambe
pas à sa demande le premier importateur
de grands crus bordelais y veillent en
permanence
il vient justement d'écouler un énorme
stock de bordeaux pour calmer les prix
qui s'envolait nous absorbons les grands
chocs de prix de surtout les
augmentations qui vient des fois
brutalement subitement nous nous
répercutons pas ça dans nos prix devant
nous nous faisons désormais en
augmentation très graduelle qui permet
la réservation à l'absorption de ces
vins par le marché un archi qui restent
étroits puisque chaque américain ne se
donne que 10 fois par an l'occasion
d'ouvrir une bouteille de vin les
enfants ils veulent plus de liberté et
plus de respect c'est le résultat sans
surprise la sondage que vient
d'effectuer lé secrétariat d'état à la
famille auprès d'élèves de 5e et 6e
alors pour commenter ce sondage est bien
autant demander leur avis aux enfants
eux mêmes
patrick red club et chantal kimmerlin
les enfants ont-ils des droits
aujourd'hui sont ils respectés et
écoutés par les adultes peuvent-ils dès
aujourd'hui faire certaines choses sans
demander l'autorisation par exemple
s'habiller avec les vêtements de leur
choix dépenser leur argent comme bon
leur semble que maman contraignent les
idées que
que puis-je faire mais j'ai changé
parole qu elle nous considère comme une
égale à elle sa commune à serrières
dépensé seulement d'argent
ben faudrait comme je recommande de
emmené par an pour le défoncer parce
qu'elle dépenserait d'un forcément à la
maison les enfants sont punis quand ils
font des bêtises quelquefois ils sont
bas qu il y à la gifle l'a fait c'est
plus dur encore la ceinture mais il
yad'autres sorte de punition
privé de télé privée de sortie il note
avec une ceinture que ça j'aime pas trop
c'est un peu trop martyrs recevoir une
gifle acceptable mais pas de vautours
être privés de télévision
c'est pas parce que je regarde pas trop
trop la télé comment les enfants vivent
l'école se sentent ils responsables
concernés
exemple un élève étrangers fait une
grosse faute de français toute la place
riz comment réagit-il le français s'est
un peu dire ça c'est dur et même un
français pour faire une faute comme ça
normal c'est injuste parce que
être lui dire qu'il a fait une bêtise
c'est tous les blessés sont ils
sensibles à l'injustice pour moi et pour
la russie ce soit mon père ma mère d'un
aura l delà de l'argent de poche et en
abstrait des jouets à mon frère et ma
soeur alors que moi je vois rien ces
canettes par rapport à moi chute elle
entre élèves
en sport tout de suite le basket les
français jouent en ce moment même en
championnat d'europe c'est le match de
la dernière chance
à vrai dire on ne croit plus beaucoup
qu'ils vont se qualifier pour les demi
finales puisque s'ils ont battu la
bulgarie avant-hier
hier ils ont été battus par la grèce
hélas alors derniers espoirs
c'est le match contre la yougoslavie qui
se joue en ce moment même
mais cette équipe de yougoslavie est
l'une des plus fortes du monde et le
match a lieu à zagreb en yougoslavie
alors tout de suite jean ma mère où en
est on dans ce match eh bien écoutez les
français sont menées 98 84 avec rat jack
et aux lancers francs cela va mal je
dirais pour les français qui ont
pourtant fort bien résisté dans cette
rencontre vous l'avez dit très
importante contre la yougoslavie les
français bien sûr sont en blanc ici l
attaque avec dacoury et les yougos des
yougoslaves qui mène donc maintenant
largement et qui vont s'envoler vers une
troisième victoire ils sont d'ores et
déjà qualifiés pour les demi finales de
la coupe d'europe
la yougoslavie qui a eu cinq titres de
champion d'europe et deux titres de
champion du monde c'est donc une équipe
de haute volée mais les français les ont
inquiété jusqu'au bout puisque à la mi
temps les français emmenés de 8 points
ils ont même conservé cet avantage toute
une partie de la deuxième mi temps
malheureusement et non pas pas tenues
vraiment physiquement face à lille
yougoslave a mené surtout par leur
meneur de jeu petrovic sans doute l'un
des meilleurs joueurs du tournoi
alors maintenant tout n'est pas terminé
même si la télé français qui jauge en
rente n'est pas terminée pour l'équipe
de france puisqu'elle aura comme
prochain match la hollande a rencontré
ce sera un match pour la 6e place puis
ensuite ce sera l'espagne pour tenter de
remporter la 5e place qui sera la
dernière place qualificative pour le
mondial de l'an prochain il reste donc
un mince espoir ce soir
malgré cette défaite assez large mais
tout de même honnête
de la france face à lui new business le
match s'est terminé là jean il reste
environ 50 secondes de jeu effectif
c'est à dire un peu peut être trois à
quatre minutes de jeu puisque au basket
vous ne l'ignorez pas c'est le jeu
effectif on arrête le chronomètre chaque
fois qu'il ya un un aride ballon les
français ne pourront plus remonter donc
merci merci jean résultats encore le tir
fait nous allons voir tout de suite
l'ordre d'arrivée c'est de ce tiercé
c'était 6 18 15 nous n'avons pas encore
les rapports puisque le tiercé avait
lieu à longchamp en fin d'après midi
seulement mais il y avait un kart et ses
6 18 15 et 11 pas de rapport non plus je
voulais 10 à cause de la chaleur ont
cours en fin d'après-midi maintenant
pour la fin de ce journal la météo s'est
tout de suite avec laurent cabrol la
dernière édition ce sera henri sannier
vers 23h50 à peu près c'est à dire après
édition spéciale
l'émission présentée par claude sérillon
et consacré à l'armée ce soit au service
militaire précisément et puis demain
télé matin sera consacré un sujet très
amusant les fils à papa autour du livre
d'olivier lerner le voici fils à papa ça
s'intitule alors avec notamment demain
dans télématin quelques fils à papa
célèbre paul belmondo
olivier barre eric peugeot et dominique
baudis le maire de toulouse dans les 4
vérités donc le nom qu'est pas ce rendez
vous puis à 13 heures comme d'habitude
william leymergie patricia charnolé
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 bonsoir